[Applause]
[Music]
you've probably already heard the news
Iran is going to resume its nuclear
program but do they really intend to
build nuclear bombs well this is what
the Supreme Leader of Iran Ayatollah
Khamenei says building and stockpiling
nuclear bombs is wrong and using them is
Haram religiously forbidden even though
we have nuclear technology Iran has
firmly rejected it Ayatollah Khamenei
that's right if you ask an Iranian
politician he'll tell you that they only
want nuclear energy for peaceful
purposes nuclear power plants medical
equipments and that sort of thing so
then you might be thinking well that's
fantastic but why doesn't the United
States believe them are they just
looking for an excuse to impose economic
sanctions or are there actual compelling
arguments to indicate that Iran wants
atomic bombs well by the end of this
video you'll understand what's going on
here
but first let's keep one thing in mind
the greatest power of an atomic bomb
isn't its power to destroy but its power
to deter so it could be that Iran wants
an atomic bomb to make sure nobody tries
to destabilize the regime
[Music]
think about it they have plenty of
enemies if Saudi Arabia and its allies
Israel and above all the United States
seen from their perspective it makes
sense for them to want a nuclear arsenal
but then comes the big question which
I'm sure many of you have pondered as
well supposing Iran wants to have
nuclear bombs
why don't they already have them I mean
the Iran nuclear program has been going
on for eighteen years now and nuclear
bomb technology is not exactly new the
first nuclear warhead dates back to 1945
in fact much poorer and less developed
countries than Iran already have nuclear
bombs for example North Korea and
Pakistan
so the question is if they've managed to
do it well why not
Iran are they really seriously arming
happens more importantly are they able
to build such weapons today we're going
to answer all of these questions but
before we do we have a bit of an
announcement this Friday February the
14th we're going to post a very special
interview we're going to have with us
the Secretary General of NATO jens
stoltenberg as you know that weekend's
is when the Munich Security Conference
takes place and visual politic will be
doing coverage there alongside other
YouTube giants like Leroy Matata and Ana
Kasparian from The Young Turks you can
find all the interviews and content will
be doing on the channel your MSC the
link to this channel is in the
description below so you can subscribe
to that for great political contents
we'll also include the interview with
mr. Stoltenberg here a visual politic
unfortunately I can't do them to be
myself so instead of me one of the guys
from the Spanish Channel Fonseca is
going to be going there and he's
obviously gonna be doing in English so
remember that day Valentine's Day we
have the most romantic plan for you a
date to have one of the most important
political leaders in the world today the
Secretary General of NATO here on visual
politic which is great and with that our
way let's take a look back at the
history
[Music]
how to build a nuclear power plant
nuclear technology can be used for lots
of things
power plants medicine and yes nuclear
bombs in all these applications the
physical process is the same
fission this is one of the greatest
scientific discoveries of the 20th
century and it involves scientists like
Einstein Fermi and Mike nur by the way
before we continue we're not experts in
science so we have to give credit for
this section to Javier Sante Lala here's
one of the physicists who discovered the
Higgs bosons sometimes called the god
particle and he is also one of the best
science youtubers in Spanish you can
find a link to his channel in the
description below if you speak Spanish
that said how does nuclear fission
actually work so it all starts with an
atom a very heavy atom that is split
into two smaller ones nevertheless if we
combine the weight of these two new
smaller atoms the outcome would be
lighter than the original atom that's
because a small amount of energy is
released when the atomists splits it's
just a miniscule amount but remember
that a small one Poundstone has
trillions of atoms so when we liberate a
small amount of energy from each of
those trillions of atoms we get a huge
amount of power this power can be used
to create a huge explosion and this
explosion is called fission
[Music]
now all we need is a fissionable Atem
and a mechanism to trigger this reaction
because most elements are stable that
means most atoms can't be split in two
for nuclear fission you need an element
that is more unstable fermion might know
we're two scientists who discovered the
elements that makes that fission
possible that's uranium-235 so it's not
any old uranium it's only the isotope of
uranium-235 now the next step is well
how do you unleash that fission reaction
the answer is neutrons if you throw a
neutral against an atom of uranium-235
the atom breaks but that's not all that
happens
apart from releasing energy three other
neutrons are unleashed those neutrons
then hit other atoms and Kreator the
same reaction this is what we call a
chain reaction in a matter of seconds
you've unleashed a huge amount of energy
if you want those neutrons to be even
more efficient you need them to have low
energy this is why heavy water is used
as a moderator so there you have it all
you need in order to create a nuclear
bomb is uranium-235 heavy water and a
source of neutrons and at this point you
might be wondering come on sign it can't
be even that easy if this is all you
need why doesn't everyone have a nuclear
bomb and well here's the tricky part
getting your hands on uranium 235 you
see elements in nature often appear as
mixtures of different isotopes so if you
find a lump of uranium rock it will be
made of a mixture of different uranium
isotopes the uranium 235 is just 0.7% of
it that means you could hardly create
that chain reaction by using normal
uranium Rock and this is when the
enrichment process comes into the
picture enriching uranium means
increasing the proportion of uranium-235
this is where we have several enrichment
levels in its natural state uranium-235
is found at a concentration of 0.7% as
we set the nuclear plants you need 4%
for nuclear bombs you need more than 90%
and dear viewer enriching uranium is a
really complex process you can't do it
by using chemical processes but only by
using pure physics and this is why
centrifugal force is used so if you want
to buy enriched uranium on the market
you can buy five percent enriched
uranium exactly what you need for
nuclear plants but if you want to buy
uranium at a 90 percent concentration
well good luck finding a seller the
non-proliferation treaty states that
nobody can buy uranium for nuclear bombs
so basically if you want to have nukes
you've got to enrich your own uranium
that means that you need to have your
own centrifuges and develop your own
enriching technology remember at this
point about the centrifuges because it
is going to become very important
throughout the rest of this video
yes please if you're watching this video
from Spain or Germany you may be
surprised to know that in Iran nuclear
energy is incredibly popular moreover a
few months before the 1979 revolution
Persian Shah was about to finish his
first nuclear power plants using German
technology in fact he wanted to have 23
plants up and running by the year 2000
basically Iran was set to be one of the
most nuclear countries on the planet so
what happens
well first Iran underwent the revolution
of Ayatollah Khomeini and then there was
the war against Iraq which devastated
the country on top of that Iraqi
missiles destroyed the nuclear power
plants that the Shah had begun to build
so Iran had to forget about its nuclear
plants until 1995 and well what happened
in 1995 well Iran resumed its plans to
finish building its first plant the
bush-era plant
[Music]
but now Iran's new ally wasn't Germany
but Russia which explains why the bushi
reactors were from russet on a Russian
company so far nothing out of the
ordinary each country has the right to
build the nuclear power plants at once
the problem came in 2002 when Iran built
a centrifuge to enrich uranium and say
heavy water production plant and what I
said before what's the first thing you
need to build atomic bombs well exactly
that's uranium enrichment plants
[Music]
if Iran just wanted more nuclear
powerplants it could buy enriched
uranium on the open market for example
it could do this from nearby Kazakhstan
that was the first alarm why was Iran
interested in enriching their own
uranium this all explains the so-called
Paris agreement in 2003 France Germany
and the United Kingdom sat down with
Iran and said look enriching uranium
isn't a crime but we don't trust you so
if you don't mind
you want to inspect or your centrifuges
regularly that way they could ensure
that Iran wasn't enriching uranium up to
the levels needed to make bombs we're
talking about a very complicated process
basically where you can use the same
centrifuges to enrich uranium to 5% or
90% in fact if you want enough uranium
to run multiple power plants you've need
even more centrifuges than you do to
make bombs to give you an idea a nuclear
warhead needs between 15 to 20 kilograms
of uranium a factory needs 100 tons
every four years in other words in order
to make sure that Iran wasn't enriching
uranium to make bombs immense that
experts needed to be sent in to inspect
Iran's 20,000 centrifuges and that's
when the second alarm bell rang
Ronen refuses access to nuclear sites
officially Tehran allowed the inspectors
to arrive but apparently they denied
them access to many of their centrifuges
as you can imagine that led to some
mistrust but if you're not convinced
here comes the third alarm just as the
Soviet Union was wiped out and today
does not exist so will the Zionist
regime in Israel soon be wiped out
Mahmoud Ahmadinejad the former Iranian
president Iran's position is that the
cancers tumor called Israel must be
uprooted from the region Ayatollah
Khamenei Supreme Leader of Iran of
course Iran claims that they also have
the right to enrich their own uranium
without having to depend on anyone many
countries have centrifuges that doesn't
mean that they should be considered an
international threat the problem is that
having this capacity along with recent
statements and the problems when
inspectors come the scenario is more
concerning and since Iran didn't reach
an agreement with the United States nor
Europe Washington imposed the first
rounds of economic sanctions but hang on
a minute because we're still in the
first decade of the 20th century when
George Bush was president so those are
still a lot more to this story and let's
get back to it
anything to negotiate Bush and Amidon
air were in irreconcilable positions but
things changed in the 20th century Obama
was in the White House and was willing
to negotiate with Tehran on the other
side the new Iranian president was man
you see on screen right now Hassan
rouhani who had a much more centrist
profile what I truly wish is for
moderation to return to the country this
is my only wish extremism pains me
greatly we've suffered many blows as a
result of extremism Hassan rouhani
president of Iran with this new set up
the United States and Iran reached an
agreement the so called 5+1 agreements
under this Agreement Washington lifted
almost all of Iran's sanctions in return
the ayatollahs limited their uranium
enriching capabilities yes okay they
could keep five thousand of their 20,000
centrifuges but they had to lower
production basically it was more of a
symbolic issue Iran would maintain its
pride and the world could stop worrying
today because America negotiated from a
position of strength and principle we
have stopped the spread of nuclear
weapons in this region with this move
things fell into place Obama managed to
convince not only Iran but also France
Germany Russia China and the entire EU
it was also great for the ayatollahs
suddenly Iran could sell oil to the
world again companies such as Renault
and Vodafone were once again investing
in this country however both Saudi
Arabia and particularly Israel didn't
trust Tehran in 2018 Israel's Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu prepared a
PowerPoint presentation with all the
material that Mossad had obtained the
presentation showed evidence that Iran
was still developing a nuclear bomb in
secret was Netanyahu's intelligence
correct well I'd love to give you a
definitive answer but I can't
however this presentation was enough to
convince Donald Trump
[Music]
Trump announces people withdraw the u.s.
from the Iran nuclear deal and restore
sanctions if you remember about a year
ago we released a series of videos on
visual politic explaining all the
details of the sanctions against Iran
basically trumped sanctions were so
harsh they also forced the European
Union to stop doing business with Tehran
is basically led to the collapse of the
Iranian economy and for moderate leaders
like rouhani to lose all credibility
[Music]
finally Solomon is murder in early 2020
was the final straw for Iran and all
this explains why Iran has started
enriching uranium again after all what
else can Washington do to stop them and
what cards to play according to some
experts if Iran started running all
20,000 centrifuges in about one year
they could get enough enriched uranium
to make their first nuclear warheads
[Applause]
[Music]
so now here's a question for you do you
think Iran will end up building a
nuclear bomb is this their true
intention or will they reach an
agreement with the White House at the
last minute can leave your answer in the
comments below also remember that we
released brand new videos every week so
subscribe to this channel and click on
the bells that you don't miss out on any
of our updates also remember to check
and our friends from ricans to the media
the podcast that provided the vocals in
this episode that were not mine and if
you liked this video give it a thumbs up
and I'll see you in the next one if you
want to learn more about politics and
world affairs and here's some more of my
lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider at
WWE consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast
[Music]